hey leute ich stelle euch heute das
spiel happy wales im vierten test vor
und zwar ist das ein spiel wo ihr mit
irgendwelchen komischen fahrzeugen
meistens mit seinem teil wo ihr nach
vorne drückt mein vater nach vorn ich
weiß nicht genau wie die teile heißen
aber das ist auch im tutorial bzw
anfangs beginner level auch so mit
solchen teilen steuert ihr euren typen
durch komische level in einer 2d ansicht
von mario style einfach so über stock
und stein und dem ist halt es dann
durchs ziel schaffen
es ist ein sehr süchtig machen das spiel
hier seht jetzt die traditionen
ihr könnt ja auch die options einstellen
also was für eine qualität partikel
sound als audio dann könnt ihr euch auch
selber levels machen und die level laden
und euch eure wiederholungen und replays
angucken und ihr könnt natürlich auch
alle levels durchgehend die je gemacht
wurden da gibt es auf jeden fall eine
menge
hier seht ihr schon 50 seiten mehr level
editor habe ich mich noch nicht mit
beschäftigt also könnt ihr selber
rausfinden das ganze spiel könnt ihr
kostenlos auf der seite total jörg face
dot com / ap hp also der komplette link
ist in der beschreibung könnte da
kostenlos spielen
und na ja ich würde sagen wir gehen mal
ins spiel spielen mal renaissance
beginnen
und jetzt sehen wir hier ich nehme ihm
die maus aus dem bild unten drunter sind
immer die erstmal eingeblendet wie ihr
das ganze steuert und zwar mit den
pfeiltasten nach unten fährt er nach
hinten wenn ihr nach oben drückt weiter
nach vorne dann wenn ihr nach rechts
druck lehnt er sich nach vorne und nach
links hinter sich halt nach hinten
hierbei space hüpft er und das muss ich
aber auch erst mal aufladen das heißt
ich lasse jetzt aufladen dann ist er
höher
und wenn ich jetzt direkt danach hüpfen
würde wäre das halt nicht so hoch mit z
lasst ihr euer fahrzeug los und lasst
euch einfach fallen
da muss man dann immer mal ins menü
gehen und restart machen und mit shift
lehnt ihr euch halt so nach hinten und
mit wie heißt es hier steuerung so
komisch also und ich versuche jetzt mal
dieses level zu machen ist das erste mal
dass ich das hier komplett gerade mache
und da seht ihr ich denke sofort fest
beim ersten moment warte ich mal eben
hier von vorne los los los los verdammt
noch viel zu blöd für dieses spiel
also ich bin gerade wirklich das
allererste mal ich habe es bisher nur
bei nein nein ein paar youtube
ich kann da einfach ich glaube ich dann
einfach überfahren ich habe es bisher
nur bei ein paar youtube angesehen acht
cool und mein gott oh mein gott da
hinten kind los springen jedoch hoch
hannover ist nicht schwer dort soll sehr
schön und jetzt weiter hier oh mein gott
haben wir einen wirklichen kippt getötet
das ist ja jetzt kommen wir jetzt im
renaissance festival und das ist echt
interessant was hier für eine atmosphäre
herrscht hier alle leute werden
umgebracht mit denen hier oh mein gott
oh mein gott
kein kommentar so ok fahren einfach
weiter hoffe ich doch hallo
fangen wir mal bitte weiter fangen wir
mal bitte weiter halo ist noch nicht so
schwer einfach mal hier drüber zu fahren
verstehe ich gerade nicht wollen dann
ist doch geschafft einfach darauf zu
jumpen ok cool also jetzt haben wir so
einen karren pro interessant ist dass
also das ist jetzt natürlich schief
gegangen dass wir jetzt auch noch eine
person bei umgebracht hat das ist
natürlich da ja das komplette spiel das
glaube ich baue ich weiß nicht 6 12 ich
weiß es nicht
keine ahnung puzzlespiel ok oh mein gott
don't touch die routine und wir haben
schon wieder eine person umgebracht
interessant also die komplette steuerung
finde ich eigentlich ziemlich gut
mir sagen was eben mehr um mein gott was
ihr davon haltet und jetzt haben sie
schon wieder hier menschen umgehauen
ach guck mal ein rohbau dem jetzt
hochfahren wie kommen wir denn hier ohne
gott ach ich bin so gut live action so
melone
so fahren wir weiter und mein gott jetzt
ein stein und jetzt hier hoch und hier
drunter her um mein gott wie konntet ihr
darunter landen
hallo habe ich denn bitte schön das
hingekriegt
das ist jetzt interessant jetzt kann ich
doch mal theoretisch ist da kann ich da
nicht irgendwie auch wieder drunter
wegkommen naja jedenfalls war das jetzt
schon mal das zweitletzte von happy
wales ich könnte jetzt hier mein wenn
die wiederholung angucken
die wiederholung speichern und auch das
level ist einfach wieder von vorne
starten schreibt mir eure meinung zu
happy pills in die kommentare der link
und eine bewertung zu dem kompletten
spiel detailreich findet ihr wie immer
in der beschreibung außerdem auch
facebook twitter und die ganze sonstige
social network ag schreibt eure meinung
zu happy pills in die kommentare
und jetzt liegt unten auf den link und
spielt diese
einfach weil es einfach mega geil ist
naja so leute